i gotta ask you the obligatory smart guy
reboot question like i came up with a
really fresh take on how
how we can you know bring that back with
the whole cast
is there anyone special in taj's life
you know what
no and it's like that for a reason we
have a a
a facetime uh thing that we do with all
the siblings called sibling love
nobody's safe in the group chat i'll say
that
i'm really excited about welcome matt
it's got a pretty
unconventional and unique plot i really
think you need some professional help
sweetheart i don't understand what's
happening you suffer from agoraphobia
which is
a fear of going outside due to trauma
loss
[Music]
how do you describe the movie to people
matthew hillard is a
writer director who gains a little bit
of fame and recognition
from a movie he did called life a beach
so in the process of gearing up for his
next film there's a lot of pressure on
him to sort of meet the expectations
that the first film met
he goes through a very traumatic
experience and we find out what that
experience is in the film and it sort of
derails him completely it's really funny
but it's also
pretty intense at times so i think it's
got a great balance of the comedy and
the drama
some moments you're cracking me up you
know stuffing chinese food into your
face and then other moments you
absolutely
gutted me and and and made me emotional
and made me
tear up so what was it like for you
being a part of a movie that that feels
really demanding
wow thank you thank you for saying that
um
that means a lot because that's one of
the reasons why i wanted to do the role
because uh you know a what it's speaking
up and what it's bringing awareness to
but also it's a chance for people who
may know me
already to see me in a different light
it was very demanding
in in all in all areas but that's why i
do what i do right there's no film
there's just you
in this house afraid to go outside i
know that this film is a work of
fiction it's very exaggerated but you
yourself
someone who's been in the public eye
you've had a lot of success
have you ever been compelled to take a
step back maybe take a break
and say how to pump the brakes for a
minute here
i do that often and i and and you know
i think it's good for me and for my
mental health for my
you know family life whatever to step
back and take breaks after i finished
baby daddy it kind of disappeared for a
little bit
now here i am and i think that's healthy
and i think it helps to sort of
separate the hollywood glitz and glamour
from
real life i would be remiss to sit here
and not talk a little bit about the past
and the projects that we grew up
watching you doing and
and still are so beloved and cherished
today
um i'm curious when you go out what is
the number one
role or project that people tend to
approach you about or recognize you for
it's probably just a combination of
smart guy and full house with like
a like you'd be surprised at the amount
of kim possible fans i run into
impossible fans are just hardcore man
they just they
love it i cannot afford this jacket i
know
i pulled up your bank account you're
broke so taj
of course i gotta ask you the obligatory
smart guy reboot question i want you in
school
why i take one year off i'll still be
four years ahead
do you want to revisit tj henderson
there's been lots of zoom meetings and
talks about this so we we do have the
ball rolling on it
it's just a matter of uh of uh of time
and timing but um we do have you know
the the possible home for it we do have
a writer
um and i came up with a really fresh
take on how
how we can you know bring that back with
the whole cast
and and something that is fresh and new
but also
something that you know the the die hard
fans will still uh
you know get that nostalgic aspect of it
as well
so i just i gotta go through the
questions now who's on board
who from the cast is gonna return
the perfect world you will see the whole
cast the person that's been in the
most contact with me about it and me
with him
is probably john marshall jones who
played my father in in the show
um and obviously i i was just working
with essence on
on the new pilot that we're both so you
got to give me a little tease where are
we going to find tj
in 2021 um
i'm treading lightly here come on world
friends
it's just two old friends having a gap
yeah we do go way back
don't we okay let me see let me see you
will find
tj just as he was
in the original a fish out of water
right he was
uh sort of exploring a new world uh
for himself you'll find him in that same
situation
but somewhere else tj is the only thing
yes he you you that's not a problem
you'll be able to see him maybe
have a you know a tequila on the rock
there you go
okay before we move off of smart guy
completely i just have to go back to one
of my favorite episodes
oh my god it's destiny's childhood
that's who we're looking at no he's so
cute you could just eat them for dessert
grab a spoon girls what do you remember
about filming that episode
everything had the biggest uh crush on
latavia
um and latoya and
all of them let's be real beyonce and
kelly come on
like some i think it wasn't latoya i you
know you know you got to find that one
you know and i found my one
on set you know but i'm you're the one
with lachlan
my one was latoya and you know to be
able to show my tax dancing skills you
know with beyonce i mean i know she
still gotta remember
i know i know what you do
[Music]
i have to commend you and i'm sure you
hear this all the time that
you are just so level-headed you're
grounded we only hear
wonderful positive things about you and
your family
and um and i'm curious if you think that
has anything to do with the fact
that you know you took a little break
from acting you went to regular high
school you played football you went to
college you think that that helped you
avoid you know the typical pitfalls of
childhood stardom i most definitely
think so that i wouldn't have done those
things if it weren't for
our amazing parents you know i gotta
give it
all to them i was going back to regular
school
public school after i was on set you
know what i mean so
i think that helped me stay normal
in this sense and to realize that you
know it was just a job it wasn't like
a complete um it wasn't my life it was a
job that i did that i'm very
thankful i still get to do but i went
home afterwards and hung out with my
friends and
went to football and track practice and
had homework
just like all the other kids do so i
definitely
think that was a a huge a huge reason
why i
am somewhat normal you're still so young
and you've achieved
so much i'm curious what is on the taj
mori
bucket list i i wrote a screenplay
and this summer we're gearing up
um to go into production on that and
it'll be
my directorial debut so i'm uh
i'm very very excited it's a blend
of get out and skeleton keys and that's
that's that's all i'll say about that
there's a lot of teas in the houses
tia tamara so when i'm trying to call
one of them
sometimes i'll call him tave sometimes
i'll call him she'll run down the whole
list
until one stick it's it's so beautiful
to watch
tian her family and tamara and her
family and your brother tavior just got
married
so i have to ask is there anyone special
in taj's life
you know what no and it's like that for
a reason
i do want to get married and have have
children with
with with a beautiful wife to be at some
point but
i'm not in a rush also um
i also want to make sure that my mind is
right mentally that that i've
taken enough time to to uh to give
myself the love that i need
to be able to uh to give it to to to
that special lady
in the future but i do want to be a dad
at some point i love kids
what what qualities are most important
to you when you're looking for a partner
space um uh i i was
i was just explaining to someone there's
nothing sexier to me
than like a boss woman you know so i
would like to
that jay-z beyonce sort of thing you
know where you both are
in your own right confidence faith
um funny i'm i i look at myself as a
funny dude and i like to laugh
i'm also really chill so like maybe not
so much on the high maintenance side and
just on the topic of family i have to
tell you
i spoke with both of your sisters
separately throughout quarantine
and in october tamara told me that she
still hadn't seen tia in person
i still haven't seen her physically um
no
i i i have to six months no
because i live in napa is this the
longest you've ever gone in life
um yeah i'm curious now that we're here
in march
have you had your opportunity to have
your family reunion
with tamara yet yes i have i
was able to see my sister um and then
also
for easter the day before easter we will
finally be able to get the whole family
together to see each other
what was it like for you to be there
with your whole family
after the roommates had to spend so much
time apart
i love that the womb mate it was
honestly really beautiful
my brother and i joke around all the
time because when they're together
no one else matters
hey hey see ya tamira uh i got a
question no and they're just
i know right and then that's the bottom
line it's just like
i'm right here um but it was beautiful
we have a a a facetime uh thing that we
do with all the siblings called sibling
love
and and we all four of us get on face
time together and we try to do it as
often
as possible we have group chats on text
we have a group chat on instagram we
have our
facetime group so we're always you know
we're always
you know together but it was beautiful
seeing them
and god they missed like you could just
tell how much they
like they missed their sister you know
and it was it was beautiful
it was beautiful what goes down in that
group chat oh it goes down
it goes down you know it goes down um
we're all jokesters so we all we all
kind of like
we get on each other in the in a fun way
you know what i mean
um nobody's safe in the group chat i'll
say that
for example i posted a picture of all of
us um
on a facetime uh not too long ago and
tia was like
crying in it but like i didn't care
like he is crying tamira's like on the
verge of tears and xavier and i are just
laughing hysterically
at the fact that she is crying so that's
what i mean
no one's safe like you're gonna get
you'll get got you know what i'm saying
yeah for sure for sure no sibling is
safe here
[Music]
you